So now, let's see what happens when we do out of
order load store execution. That is, we try the aggressive approach of
loads going to memory as soon as they know the address, if
there is no preceding store that is also the same address. And
it later turns out that a store has been resolved to
the same address. We have something like this: This is going to be
our sequence of instructions in the load store queue. Let's say that
we are executing these five instructions and this is their program order.
First we have a load that loads from the
address 0 plus R6, and puts the value into R3.
Next we have an add that takes R3, adds R9 to it and puts the result to us into
R7. Next we have a store that takes the
value from R4 and puts it in a memory location
determined by R7. Next we have a subtraction R1 minus
R2 goes into R1. And finally, we use R1 as
an address to access memory and put the value
into R8. In an out-of-order processor, when we try to
execute these instructions, this is what might happen. Let's say,
that all of these have already been fetched, decoded, etc.
So, let's say that the Load, because it only depends
on R6 switch. No other instruction is supposed to produce,
it can dispatch. So it goes to memory and, eventually,
it will come back with R3. But let's say it's
a cache miss, so it's going to take a
while until this Load comes back. This instruction cannot
be dispatched until that happens. And this instruction cannot
be dispatched until that happens. In fact, the store doesn't
even know the address to which it's going to be
storing, until the add completes, which is going to happen
at some future point. Meanwhile the subtract can dispatch
and it produces R1 very quickly. At that point the
load can dispatch. It has everything it needs to
know. It has the address, now it can go to
memory and load from it. Let's say that the load
is cache hit, so it gets the R8 very quickly
and maybe supplies it to subsequent instructions. So at
this point in time. What we have is that the
subtract and load have completed, we think we're just waiting
to commit them. The load and the add, and the
store are not done yet; because they're all waiting
for the load to finish and then they can do
something. Eventually let's say that this load is done, now
we produce r 3 feed it to this add. The
add is going to be done very soon afterwards and now
we feed the R7 to the store. And now let's
say that this was some address X that we have
accessed here. If this results do not X, meaning the
address addressed by R7 is not the same address as
the one addressed by R1. Then everything is going to be
fine. The store is storing to some other address, we
have loaded something else entirely and everything is fine. However,
the problem occurs when the address that the store resolves
to si also x. At that point, the value from
R4 that the store is storing is really the one
that the load should have been loading, however the load
already loaded some stale value from memory.